folks this just in over the wire we got
a hot new merch drop get back drop baby
from november 8th to november 18th you
can get your limited edition toddy's
goodies we're asking everyone to remain
calm
we're gonna have a real black friday
situation on our hands we got bernie's
teas and hoodies we got hoodies tees we
got hoodies tees and hoodies we got
bunkos we got bonkos tees and hoodies
guys uh the link will be in the
description go to bonfire.com
are you garbage limited edition only
available for 10 or 11 days get them
while they're available get the holiday
orders in now welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out if they grow
up to be classy or if they're just a big
old piece of trash i'm your host age
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antootie's basement
she's upset upstairs why squirrels
okay she's got squirrels okay my co-host
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's
international businessman we all know
him as kj but his mama named them kevin
james ryan hey gang kj's really sticking
by the way uh
what's up thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are
[ __ ] cooking and then i would be an
[ __ ] if i didn't mention the greatest
website of all time patreon.com are you
garbage
shout out to the yam family jack conte
for creating the world's best website uh
you can sign up get all bonus content
live streams the whole nine yards check
it out conti yam 2024 i'm calling it
right [ __ ] i'm in and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer jordan
there the magic man makes us all look
good
busting his ass the kid's the [ __ ]
best give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what's up dudes we've been
having a real good time about to have an
even better time we got the homie in the
crib it's gonna be fun
we could not be more excited to have our
incredibly special guest that i mean
incredibly special guest we got a little
[ __ ] star power he does some numbers
over there with us today for the first
[ __ ] time he is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian actor
podcaster youtube and social media
[ __ ] sensation he is the co-host of
the stiff socks podcast he's got
573 followers on the twitter there
2 million on the ground and are you
ready for this put your seat belts and
your headgear on 2 million 260
subscribers on youtube the kid is a
[ __ ] network unto himself
big question about his mind today is he
garbage not with that hairline baby i'll
tell you that right now that jacket says
different though yeah i'll throw you off
i'm like a four loka you know i'm classy
the inside i see going in yeah trash oh
something
camouflage and you crack and you're like
oh no another felony
give it up for trevor wallace
yeah this is great dude oh buddy that's
got to be an expensive jacket though uh
this is a thrift find for sure really i
think this was 24 bucks wow it looks
cool yeah i don't know what it is uh but
you got that vibe where you can you can
pull stuff off that's not cool you can
make cool davis and [ __ ] where are yours
yeah cause at a certain level people
just go is it am i missing a trend here
is this the new thing yeah
i saw pete davidson like three weeks ago
and i was wearing a fanny pack for the
first time he's like oh you got a fanny
pack i'm like yeah he's like i got a
purse i'm like okay we're wearing a
shower curtain
dude literally yeah he can do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants yeah i'd be so nervous
if i saw pete i'd probably just go naked
this is the news oh dude i was so
self-conscious the whole time you had a
fanny pack i had a fanny pack on and uh
somebody was like just no proper rake
and they were like kevin is that a fanny
pack i'm like yeah it's the first time
wearing it i'm not quite sure it's like
ah dude fanny packs are cool i'm like
all right that's great because i think
had you done over the chest then he
would have been like all right man let's
be honest i can't do that i'm not that
cool yeah yeah i can't got it
can you pull that off is that cool now
no i i cause you're right there there
was a split second where like that was
like the move and i still think a little
bit is uh i i just i also don't carry
enough [ __ ] on me to like put anything
in there sure you know if it's just
empty and it's like flying off
so if there's nothing in it or there's
like one weird thing like an iphone cord
in there you're like you could just put
that on your back that's a back pocket
right there yeah i'd rather go backpack
or in uh williamsburg a lot of people
out here they just got the tote bags
tote bags i like a nice tote it's uh i
do not i want to go
but i can't pull it off you hold it for
like five minutes and you're like this
is i wish i had a backpack yeah this is
so annoying i think yeah yeah i think
the non-backpack's a physical thing for
you but the question is are they cool
now
i think they definitely are you know
probably in a certain you know zip code
in brooklyn yeah yeah they also look
like you're saving the environment
somehow somewhere another and i don't
want to be represented as that there we
go i'm a classic bag
there we go get a wegmans bag yo [ __ ]
wegman's very classy i'll tell you what
those bags are awesome too i travel with
those bags from the grocery store the
reusable bags oh really you know what i
heard that's how trashy he is that's
what gets on the airplane with like a
shopping they don't like question it as
a carry-on you hold it like it's
groceries meanwhile it's a [ __ ]
cardigan in a fanny pack
you're home like an old like old school
like yeah yeah but they think it's just
like food because i don't know you could
even you can bring food on a flight
i know that's a question we do a lot
would you do do you do that dude i my
dad did the most rogue thing ever see
him i feel like my trashiness comes from
like a background of like it has nice uh
in a way intuitions
but it comes off bad sure like i was
flying back from hawaii situations is
not the right word but i know what you
mean
i'm not going to strike number one
i'm not good with english it comes from
like uh like i don't know it's coming
back from hawaii with my dad which is
just a
genuine you know piece of [ __ ] statement
but my dad midway through the flight
pulls out a ziploc bag and he had a
chicken tender
from the restaurant
so you brought a tender through tsa is
that even legal one just one tender and
he taps you on the shoulder because
you're sitting behind me in [ __ ] main
cabin like a [ __ ] just kidding wait
okay wait you were flying first i didn't
know we were the same
that's like richie richie right now i
don't know but he like tapped me on the
shoulders like you wanna bite i was like
did you bring that in your pocket
dad we're both doing well enough we
don't need to split attention
but it was weird he goes the pocket kept
it kind of warm
and you need my father on the show
immediately oh my god so now we got to
go back since you said that give us the
origin story of trevor wallace where are
you from what's the school cali boy
right cali kid essentia was born in
naperville illinois but was there for
two years okay where's
oh bears should have [ __ ] known
wow should have seen that huge bear yeah
i still know if you guys are trying to
cover a hole in the wall or something
for the listener i'm sitting next to an
eight-foot bear bear's flag
uh no so i was born in illinois because
uh my parents brought it for work my
mom's from california she's like [ __ ]
this it's cold yeah they moved back when
i was two so i spent all my life in
southern california nice
it's fine yeah like town of sixty
thousand i think that's uh suburban
suburban upbringing yeah yeah so close
to l.a
uh about hour near the beach
about 20 from the beach it was like a
little inland hour from the from l.a but
you could get to either of those like on
the weekends we would drive down to
venice beach and like go buy like a pipe
yeah [ __ ] nice one hitter or
something yeah one hitter dude a bubbler
if you're [ __ ] oh dude i haven't
heard bubbler in [ __ ] 20 years but
that was right yo get the bubbler but
when one like my buddy cj would bust out
the bubbler
[Laughter]
that was always a cj that had a bubbler
too oh yeah because he was the one that
had like the chiller parents yeah like
they still would get mad but they walked
in they bit gay come on hide a little
better every bubbler was in a sock too
yeah pull it out of a sock yeah a dirty
tube socket yeah dude what the [ __ ] and
the water came in this recently yeah
it's like hides the smell yeah it's
disgusting but the water would barely do
anything but mentally we're all like
ninth grade like this is [ __ ] sick
yeah filtration just that noise that
noise alone
if you feel like you're in a cycle
we used to do something and i don't know
if the term is the best now but it's
called a ghetto where you smoke out of
it would be it would be a water bottle
and you take a pen pen cap yeah you'd
find like an uh a socket socket wrench
yeah you'd burn it on the on the pen you
put it in there and that was your bong
that would create like a tight enough
seal at the pen and then you put uh like
a hole in it as like a carb yeah but you
know talk about the [ __ ] the sound
did you put one of those on a gatorade
box oh dude you're looking rich
yeah yeah nice big gator that big mouth
on the gatorade bottle will get cooking
dude
we felt like we were doing an interlude
for a sublime song
no that was uh so yeah grew up out there
brother sisters got an older sister she
lives in uh the city actually living in
the city sorry yesterday came to the
show how much older she's two years
older two years older so you guys are
growing up together yeah growing up
together pretty close we were never like
close like
but like
i don't know how to like we were cool
but we were like cool like cordial you
weren't like hanging out right
you know you see that comic in clubbing
oh what's up we're boys but like that
level
would she associate with you in high
school like she when she was older not
really but like that we'd be at the same
high school for like uh two years would
be like freshman sophomore year then
she'd be a junior senior uh but she was
just like a really good straight a
student but senior year she started
partying a little bit and that's when we
kind of like meshed because that was a
piece of [ __ ] off the bat i mean check
out him hit this bubbler
exactly the first time i smoked weed was
out of a light bulb so that
all my thomas edison [ __ ] yeah okay okay
the mailman just walked in
he's like what are you all doing in here
you don't need light bulbs dude no one's
ever opened that door ever i thought it
was a hit
and what did your mom and dad do that's
crazy uh
mom
dad's retired right now he was in sales
worked in the bicycle industry random
okay he worked for like diamondback
bicycles oh really [ __ ] yeah oh they
were pretty good rigs yeah dude he's
doing that my mom's always been like
marketing and like journalism my mom
worked for like a food magazine she
would like do like articles and [ __ ] so
your dad was working for diamondback in
the in the 90s in the height of
diamondbacks they were diamondbacks they
were big back then oh yeah dude my dad
was hitting key bumps off bikes
he had front and back pegs yeah yeah
yeah exactly
but uh he was super into that and uh he
retired he retired right before the
pandemic which [ __ ] sucks
because he's like i just want to golf
with my boys all right
here's to the rest of my life shut it
down he did well at diamondback i would
assume i i don't know if my parents may
i have no idea how much money my parents
brought in i asked one time and my mom
was like that's a rude question
absolutely so not much
she would hate our show by the way
that's all we want to know i i had no
idea so but i think he was somewhere
high up in diamondback and then they
were like all right we're moving to
washington my mom's like hey
no we ain't oh the company was the
company was so they stayed and then my
dad did some like odd sales jobs around
sold fruit at one point sold led lights
for another just whatever yeah he's on
some tires
yeah but um
did that and then when i was 17 that was
when uh
that was the first time i ever did stand
up when i was 17. no [ __ ] yeah wow yeah
there was a comedy club i don't know if
you guys ever heard of it or played it
but it's called the ventura harbor
comedy club no yeah it's a it's like a b
room but you know like they would get
like uh i'm trying to think they would
get somebody who was like popping down
like def jam in the 90s on like a
tuesday and it'd be like a big deal yeah
yeah yeah and then i would like i would
go there and i'd kind of like do the
cliche like seat people or like bus
tables and like host the off nights yeah
no [ __ ] but when i was 17 they had a
comedy club is this pre videos like when
did you start making videos videos were
in college when i was like 20. okay
that's when you started doing yeah yeah
when vine kind of popped off so i
started stand up and i've always loved
comedy you know i was all i'd ever
watched was just comedy movies and all
that so it's always just super into like
you know anything jim carrey robin
williams all those guys and uh the first
time i did stand up with 17 because my
mom very cliche disney channel-esque
[ __ ] she cut out like an ad from the
paper and it was like local comedy club
workshop
you know and uh the guy who owned the
club had been a road guy and done cruise
ships for like 50 years and he's one of
those guys sure like led a class and
they're just like you literally like you
do like workshops he'd like cut out a
newspaper article like make a joke about
this or something and i just like did
some of that and then i found some nine
dead in israel
and i did
should have been eight and for the
menorah come on
so your mom was the one that encouraged
me that's really [ __ ] cool because
you would express interest in you said
hey i want to be a comic yeah because i
didn't really have a path and they knew
i was kind of like dabbling in like not
a great lane by just smoking super early
and they caught me drinking early on too
no sports in high school
tried yeah yeah i played basketball my
junior year out of like like a men's
league but you're not really a man
in high school yeah yeah i don't know
what do you call that a uh
pre-teen league
i don't know but i
was the first guy to get a felony not a
felony
a technical foul nothing so i'll take it
yeah i was playing defense and i pushed
him and i said
bro some 55 year old accountant yeah but
uh oh that's [ __ ] great so yeah i did
that stand-up thing and then i really
liked that and i started just hanging
around the club and then went to college
in san jose san jose state university
it's closer to where you where you grew
up uh like six hours it's closer to san
francisco it's like a bear you're going
north all right yeah it's like uh you
know on the outskirts of the bay area if
it's technically the same [ __ ] but um
then when i was there
i spent two of my first years there just
fretting it up just college piece of
[ __ ] slapping the bags pace in my
bedroom
and then my the end of sophomore year
vine came out my buddy was like dude you
got to make some of these vid you got to
like hop on there and then i just like
fell in love with the creating process i
was going to film school at the time in
san jose which is like a joke of a film
school yeah where they just match like
four things like journalism radio tv
film and there's like three teachers
like hey we do it all right but uh yeah
i did that and taking home eck in
college yeah yeah that's a tough look
yeah you got the same teacher for
multiple classes in college that's
[ __ ] real
teaching women's studies
i got recess later yeah but uh then i
was starting to do vine stuff and then i
started doing open mics in college again
and i was just holding myself
accountable like i'm not going to drink
this week unless i do an open mic and
then i just kind of held myself
accountable because there was a scene in
sandy and san jose and there still is
you know there's people out there so you
could get up a couple times in a week
that's great and then i had what i
thought was a tight ten moved to l.a
went to one mic i was like ah trash
goodbye did you finish school did you
finish college i finished college uh so
how big did you get on vine from i had
like 15 000
people okay and i had like one video
that i popped off but that was enough
for me to see how a video can kind of
work sure right snowball it's like you
post it gets a little traction and then
from there you just catch this bug and i
gotta [ __ ] do that every day you're
chasing the dragon yeah exactly yeah
yeah and i'm addicted to heroin
but it all worked out hey but i got
verified so we're good you know
but uh yeah it's like you know i was
like i got i i was like i got a tight 10
and i know how to go viral and both of
those was very far from knowing and then
i kind of just
moved to la and then that's when vine
died out and then for the first like two
and a half three years of la i just did
open mics open my mics and then i
started posting videos again in like
2017 and just really doubled down i was
like video every week let's [ __ ] go
let's instagram it on youtube instagram
youtube and facebook that's uh that's
the first place i had a video papa's
face really yeah i mean there's no
competition it's you and [ __ ] fouchy
post so it's just like whatever
so it was just like yeah so i i had a
video post that on there when that got a
little steam and then i was like [ __ ]
double down what was the first big one
after
vine yeah i was making fun of the
because i know the story zoomies so it
was that was the zoom yeah it was the
zoomies character that was the first
thing that popped for me in like 2017
and then i just did a couple character
videos with that and then i was like i
don't want to be known as a zoomies guy
let me try to get away from this yeah
and then i tried a bunch of other [ __ ]
that flopped and then i had some other
things hit i did something about airpods
and then i was a new like oh then i
transferred like the zoomies got to the
airpod guy i was like [ __ ] yeah we got
out of the first one it's doable so now
let's just keep creating [ __ ] that way
it's not like you're that one guy you
know i just want to be that one guy is
it still just you at this point yeah is
there somebody helping you film or
anything i got a filmer yeah i gotta
call my guy but um so you and your boy
when'd you start seeing a little cash
from this a little bit of care a little
bit
like the end of 2018 i
was able to quit my
day job and just do comedy okay because
that's from youtube or yeah so youtube
and then you got the on youtube and
facebook they're coming out to see you
and all that yeah and i started having
people you know and at this point in
standup i was like uh i was probably
just like featuring at best yeah or
doing some hosting and i would like post
like there was gonna be shows and like
people more people would come out to see
this sounds like really cocky i'm sorry
but like more people would come out to
see me as the feature of the host yeah
than the headliners yeah you're probably
opening for some guy who yeah and they'd
be like why didn't you do more you're
like
[ __ ] yeah
i don't know because they're giving me
25 bucks i'm only about to eight minutes
yeah exactly so and then i talked to
somebody like dude just set up your own
one-nighters yeah no [ __ ] ain't no
future no more kids you're moving
dickies yeah i didn't know you could
just do that yeah that's great and then
i called up the first place i ever did
was in san diego it was like uh it was
called comedy palace and i was like hey
can i do a one-nighter and then i was
they were like yeah we got you on the
counter and then i had like a month to
be like okay what's the 45 i have first
45 headlines said i did i mean all over
the place yeah yeah i mean there was
parts where i was like hey make some
noise if you like birds you know
it's always tough when you were you're
like uh you're like 35 minutes and
you're like oh my god i was talking
about bikes 14 minutes ago you remember
that you're forgetting about looking for
the light audience it doesn't matter
yeah but you know i was just sewing my
head and i and i probably had a light 25
at the point but you kind of just were
like all right we're gonna [ __ ] see
what happens yeah that's great dude
but you know i threw myself in the deep
end and you kind of just repetition
repetition yeah of course
now you got a light 27 you're [ __ ]
out
two years later 28. so how old are we
talking you when i was doing this yeah
this is happening probably like 25.
jesus that's young yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah and but this is like a you know a
tuesday at like 9 00 p.m or something
[ __ ] okay how about those good people
over there at helix mattresses helix
mattresses my favorite people in the
whole wide world yes they are gang take
the quiz go over there take the quiz
helix mattress you don't want to be
walking on a mattress store like a bozo
i don't know about this coin i don't
know about that one you do helix you
take the quiz you find out how you sleep
sleep heavy sleep light sleep hot sleep
cold you could sleep big who knows and
they got plus-sized mattresses for you
big boys out there and gals uh
yeah guys i to me and my wife they were
you know the good folks at helix were
nice enough to send me and my wife a
mattress jumped on took the two minute
quiz we're a twilight mattress man
that's what i am uh it's fantastic best
nice seat in my life first time i had an
adult mattress if you're in the market
for a mattress check them out right away
uh helix is awesome but don't take my
word for it as we've said a bunch of
times they were picked number one best
overall mattress of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just to name a few
uh go to helixsleep.com garbage take the
two minute quiz and they'll match you to
a customized mattress they'll give you
the best sleep of your life 10-year
warranty and if you get to try it out
for a hundred nights free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but i'm telling you you will you're
gonna love it uh helix is offering up to
two hundred dollars up to up to two
hundred dollars off all mattresses and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helix sleep.com garbage uh one more time
that's
healthsleep.com garbage for up to 200
off do it yeah get roman.com kippy get
roman.com get
roman.com
as the rule goes something breaks in
your house what do you do you can get a
fix i fix it what if you twist an ankle
you're going to go to the hospital
you're gonna lay there on the couch like
a bozo i go to the doctor hey doc look
at this so if you're having some ed
problems talk to the people at roman
they're gonna be able to help you they
don't just throw pills at you they talk
to you
fantastic yeah you'll get a free online
evaluation and free online evaluation
and ongoing care for e.d from all from
the comfort and privacy of your home a
us licensed healthcare official will
work with you to find if treatment is
the best if medication is appropriate it
ships right to you free with two-day
shipping whole process straightforward
discrete getting started is simple just
go to getroman.com garbage and complete
the online visit yes go to getroman.com
garbage now and you'll get 15 off your
first month it's really time to take
care of your ed and remember get started
today and you'll save 15 off your first
month of your ed treatment at
getroman.com garbage do it yes was there
a huge stupid purchase when you really
started cooking when you really
uh no because i mean i i feel like i've
always been you strike me as somebody
that's pretty conservative or yeah smart
with this [ __ ] i mean i uh jewish lad
myself grew up you know [ __ ] a he you
know getting the bar mitzvah
jewish land yeah so i like never like i
feel like i know the doc the value of a
dollar pretty well what did you get for
the bar mitzvah yeah
i think i got like
three thousand dollars
but at the time
[Applause]
but in the jewish community if the mom's
jewish it's just overrides yeah yeah of
course which is hilarious you're just
like i have zero sight zero seconds yeah
i had friends in it they didn't make
over 30 grand they left yeah but i had
kids made like a lot of cash i i mean i
don't know i i would have to ask i think
my dad was laundering the money anyways
diamondbacks tank
they need cage quick baptize the kid
again or whatever yeah mongoose is
sniffing at her heels
but when you're you end up owing money
right
yeah horror bikes too yeah but i think
three thousand dollars when you're 13
you're like i could buy an island dude i
could did you get first dibs on cool
bikes when you were a kid from
diamondback i did yeah you got free
bikes yeah but they're all like massive
ones they're like cycling bikes like
it's got six gears on my dad i just want
to try and grind on curbs and [ __ ] yeah
what's up with that trying to do a bunny
hop over here he's got a bmx out of him
yeah now he he like well he was the type
of guy he was like a bike nerd so he'd
be like you don't need this you need
that your bike season too short this and
that but um a couple of pegs let's go
bro yeah the first i was i would like
spend money on like camera gear i think
the first dumb purchase i did and uh
this is probably a schultz vibes to it
i like this was the watch oh
what you saw the clip what'd you get i
had to do it is that it had to get the
rollie on the wrist
hard hard-working kid what did you pick
when did you scoop that up that was uh
apparently like maybe like four months
ago over the summer oh so very recent
yeah literally come on that's great
up until then i haven't but the card
declined just want to let you guys know
that my girlfriend had to put it on it
really well because my credit card has a
limit on it what is it we get into that
a lot what do you think 10 000 is the
limit i thought you'd be doing better
than that this guy stinks over here
i still have a chase uh college account
like i just i have the same account i've
had
since like 2014. my parents you still
see my bank account this is not good i'm
sweating do you still go to a
pediatrician
you're sitting on a fire truck books me
the appointment yes see
yeah so
a purchase like that and i remember
uh when i was getting the watch so how
do people do the payment they do like
monthly
and the guys that's trash yeah but and
the guy goes i just just swipe and i go
like one yeah just a single and then my
card declined and i'm calling chase bank
and i keep mine i'm in hawaii for this
point this is uh a lot of hawaii we're
like we're gonna have to speak to your
mother why are we in hawaii what's with
hawaii back and forth uh this so
coincidence yeah coincidence so we had
me and my uh girlfriend plan to trip and
then covet hit and then we just pushed
it to ran a month right and then i was
supposed to go for my dad's retirement
we're supposed to go to hawaii okay they
just panned out but for me uh i got to
watch in hawaii because hawaii has four
percent sales tax
and california's like 40 i don't even
know what it is just a gun to the back
your head
why is it four percent and then i did it
i did a college gig a virtual college
gig that day and i was like i'm taking
this college channel and i'm going to
the rolly story i don't even want to
think about trans like i don't want to
see
like this on like the debit report i
wish the college just paid me in the
water
zoom talent show to make things even
better it was like a bunch of people
like singing their heart out i'm in a
[ __ ] just hillman in hawaii but yeah
this
good job go get it already
none of this is good
website yeah
yeah they're like though and what do you
write that i'm like it's not an oyster
perpetual but it's good
i love that
you're a watch guy you gonna do a rollie
sometime when we start making a real
cash that's pretty fully with the rolly
i mean
i would like to that's what my brother
has i believe that's the gentleman's
move right nice roll but that's probably
my like uh big that's definitely the
biggest purchase okay usually i like
that and you waited on it that's yeah
yeah see usually you can't be an idiot
and get a rolly that's always the guy
who knows what they're doing with their
finances
i don't know if i'll ever get there but
i am gonna be in hawaii in two weeks hey
what island uh oahu nice great one
it's the worst one i hear oh you're
gonna wait you're thinking about pulling
the trigger now i'm gonna do it i know
you don't have the money i just saw your
banks
two seconds ago you were looking at the
app maybe i'll get a rolex keychain or
something you can get a couple of things
you know dude and also
also
dude i feel like i'm fit for the show
certain moments of my life i think about
it because the links they take off the
links to fit your [ __ ] and i go oh is it
cheaper now do you yeah
no they just give you the links yeah so
now i just have three rolly links and
i'm like what do i [ __ ] do i got a
guy in the market right here yeah give
him a third of the way there yeah you
buy a child's link and then i'll give
you three and we might be able to fit uh
that's [ __ ] an adult male over here
pretty sharp kid so far
yeah pretty sharp kid let's go back your
parents don't still live in the same uh
house in southern california do they
they do
they do they just remodel it every like
eight years and they're like this is
good this is good yeah yeah yeah because
i wanted to ask you what the name of the
show yeah but can you say it was like uh
was it like a court a place street
avenue road
it's just a straight street street
basically number
uh
no no no no i think
what are you asking if it was a numbered
street yeah 112th street yeah it's a
numbered stream okay yeah all right
street what was the name of the grocery
store your mom went to growing up
vaughn's bones are you guys familiar
with vodka that's pretty that's pretty
up the middle it's vons it's like a
safeway type feel but she would prefer
trader joe she would always come home
from vaughn's and be like they didn't
[ __ ] have uh just whole grain
pomegranates like what does that even
mean yeah so these are classic these are
classy people
well my mom like wrote for like food
journalism so that's she she's gonna
lean classy in now yeah she would lean
classy and my dad was he would just make
breakfast for three meals out of the day
shout out to breakfast for dinner
the single dad's thanksgiving oh you
love it omelette at 5 p.m why not did
your parents split up where they still
together no they're still together
they're still together yeah we've had a
few uh west coast people talk about
vaughn's yeah and the the reviews been
kind of mixed someone said it was like a
wegmans you said wegmans earlier yeah i
could see that it's like safeway it's
the same kind of [ __ ] but safeway we
don't have a i don't have a safe
uh barrier here but they it's like up
the middle you guys have ralph's kroger
kroger yeah kroger kroger is to ralphs
as ralph's
ralph's yes yeah there we go and vons is
above tr ralph's
buy it buy a smidge buy a fingertip
fresh bread
uh yeah yeah
counter they got a deli counter can i
get sushi if i want yeah you can get
sushi there i'm in yeah the fish just
has a question mark next to it but they
got
they got fish with two h's yeah
just spelt like the band fish ph
there it is that's the joker
yeah but great corn dogs we used to uh
we would do this we would go to the deli
and we would your grocery store sells
corn dogs yeah i'm back to this place no
no no this thing stinks
what's this our ferris wheel what are we
doing here what's the funnel cake in the
dunk tank situation oh dude that was our
move you got five dollars what we would
do this is technically how do i say
stealing but we would take we would get
chicken tenders and a corn dog and
they're two separate bags but they both
had a different receipt on the bag and
you'd take out the corn dog put it in
the chicken tenders bag put the receipt
on the one so you pay for the price of
the chicken nuggets with a free corn dog
in there i'm all right with that it'd be
the heaviest bag of chicken tenders ever
he had a rotisserie chicken in there
like this is 2.99 who's pulling the scam
this isn't your family no no no this is
me and me and friends we were just right
i bet you cj was there for sure
100 yeah probably his idea he was out
back smoking weed out of an apple or
something
yeah we would ride our [ __ ]
diamondback bikes to the store and we'd
finesse a poor deli lady and just kind
of go from there love it
yeah now do you own a home
uh renting renting a place you're rent
yeah that's it no uh vacation property
anymore oh no no no what kind of whip
are we are we scooching around we got
that 2017 4 series bmw all right see
again german precise he's a shark he's a
sharp kid i bought it used i'm too much
of a uh dare i say jew like i can't like
i need to
get a nice thing it needs to feel like a
deal yeah
exactly i need to feel like i'm getting
i'm not paying retails for [ __ ] but
this is why he's successful right smart
kid
but i [ __ ] up i bought a car two
months before the pandemic hit uh-huh so
i could have just been in there i could
have finagled them middle pandemic and
be like hey we're all gonna die in 13
days you might
flip me that thing
but uh yeah so did that went from a
positive three yeah mazda iii had a
mazda 3 beforehand just a little sedan
did you have a car in high school i did
honda civic
2007 parents catapulted you work in high
school it was my sister's and then she
went to school in san francisco she
didn't need a car so then i got her car
it's pretty good but uh i
i had two 12-inch tough offers in the
back
well what were they jail what was it jlb
or jl yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the kid with the system in the car
anything else trash
and [ __ ] rattling what other type of
aftermarket i mean it's pretty trashy to
put a car that tops out at 83 miles per
hour just have subs in it yes you got
like three thousand dollars worth yeah i
would just be blasting walk a flock of
flame going to school
and just 2 12s and i just really thought
i was like people will want to [ __ ] me
and that was a genuine thought
anything else trash with the car no i
couldn't fit anything else in the car
it's a whole trunk space
you could fit in a basketball on the
side and that was about it but uh that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] nothing they were that
was big in high school if you had a if
you had a set of subs yeah it was big
braces headgear when you were a kid both
really yeah i had braces in middle
school i got them off freshman year
headgear yeah i had headgear widow you
wore a knight right yeah there's always
one kid there's always one kid who
pushes it it's like buddy what are you
doing there'd be one guy where's it in
broad daylight and you're like are you
trying to cut lines or something what am
i doing here
i've never seen that really no what
nobody in my high school was dare walk
people wouldn't wear [ __ ] uh
button-down shirts they'd get made fun
of yeah
i remember one kid wore a button-down
shirt in like eighth grade we were like
what are you going to a wedding or
something what are you doing dude
yeah it's like career day and they're
like what we're all gonna work at a
frozen yogurt store um what'd you get on
your sats not good i bombed the sats did
better on the acts okay act i think i
got a 24. i don't think 20 good though
is it no that's not good i don't know
much about the acts but it's out of 34
or something yeah i i was stoked i got
in the 20s though okay what was the sat
number it wasn't uh what is it out of
well they like changed they changed it
so you might have been i was in the when
you could get like a 21 was like
flawless yeah 2400 i think i got a 1300
holy [ __ ] that's bad it's bad i got that
when it was out of 1600. no my parents
looked at my mom just shed a single
teardrop it was not good what about in
college what was the gpa college started
off slow uh
that's a great way to play
so the foot traffic wasn't what we
thought it was i think anything under
2.0 you're on academic probation and i
had that young 2.1 i was right around
yeah i graduated two five four something
i felt like a [ __ ] i felt like good will
hunting yeah i was like yep but i picked
it up towards the end and got my [ __ ]
together because this was all ge classes
[ __ ] that was actually tough and then as
i progressed i got into the film classes
i was like oh this is easy yeah yeah
yeah and that's i think i finished with
like a
like a three
three two it's great did you walk in
graduation uh i did i walked uh but i
still i took a summer class after so i
like walked but i wasn't done yet yeah
yeah a little pre-cum graduation um what
was your
high school and college mascot high
school was the scorpions pretty sick
that's all right
not bad little [ __ ] stamp university
that's also a little weird yeah it's a
little sexual scorpio i've never heard
of the slurpee yeah
yeah not many scorpions out there give
it four years they'll be like this is
not okay that's weird scorpion's a
little weird yeah uh
my elementary school rival was the
butterflies that's a funny what no
elementary school rivals oh elementary
school that means first of all the
elementary schools can't be like the
predators or something you know what it
is it's gotta be depends on who's the
predator but you could yeah that would
be something sweet but uh
slicers uh
oh college was spartans san jose state
spartans which they just that's that's a
they phoned that one yeah that's they
think yeah that's like a big sports
school they were d1 but they were trash
one year we were rated 24 in football
and that was big for us we beat hawaii
on like espn2 and we were we were yeah
we found one kid with a tv on campus and
we're like this is uh this is big you
ever run out of the field college
uh i no i didn't but our favorite thing
to do is the away team their tunnel was
right by the student section so we'd
stay we'd pre-game the game [ __ ] sick
frat guy whoa and then we would uh stay
the first two quarters and then we as
they were running out the away team we
would go to their tunnel like right
there and it's a small field you know
what's that like 13 000 total yeah and
we would just yell at the player like
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you punch that's like
just a guy who can hit you oh yeah and
it would be funny because everybody
would ignore but there you always be
like one guy on the team
who maybe dropped one too many pick
sixes or something and that really got
under his skin and man [ __ ] your
beatrice and then we that'd be a that'd
be a win for us yeah you know we were
just live internet trolls that was that
was our brother you're getting off stage
at gotham somebody's like you [ __ ]
suck trevor oh yeah no i regret
everything i did
[Laughter]
college fried trevor just a piece of
[ __ ] sure i mean college is tough
there's a lot of booze you're looking
for reasons to drink you know you're all
charged up on testosterone it's all easy
yeah yeah yeah you don't know yeah
you're like a [ __ ] you don't you don't
know how to act as a person
high school favorite band favorite movie
favorite band
see i was going through a lot of phases
in high school like in freshman year
i think i listened to what year was this
freshman year uh 25
oh 2007. okay i was a freshman because i
graduated high school in 2011.
uh 2007 i was in a weird face this was
the bubbler face okay i was listening to
like your face i was listening to like
stoner music which is just like
cottonmouth kings you were listening to
the cottonmouth kings 2007 yeah no you
are dude that's uh yeah tangerine sky
there's a one song tangerine we would
put that on and listen to it
this is over
i will not stand here no it was the
trashiest thing we've ever done that's
great when we googled what the lead
singer looked like we're like we should
probably should listen to this they
dropped when i was in seventh grade dude
they probably dropped in like two like 2
000 yeah right that was probably when
they when they came around but this was
the time where it's like we would wear a
bob marley's shirt at high school so
somebody would be like oh you smoked you
smoke weed you wanted we needed that
validation sure you needed an so i think
it was a lot of that but then also like
randomly i listened to like metal like
like like death metal like really weird
like what bands like suicide silence i
don't even know has blood runs black
you got the hair for it yeah this guy's
bonko's punk rock nerd i don't listen to
that oh okay
okay okay we just lost you toby yeah
damn whatever
uh then favorite movie was probably
something like step brothers core super
bad
you know kind of a lot of that stuff uh
my favorite movie to watch hi uh super
troopers fantastic great movie but that
was you were probably young when that
hit
i think we probably watched it when uh i
don't know if we saw it like it wasn't a
theater's thing but i think we'd just
watch it like on like whatever rental
sure sure i honestly don't remember i
was too off smoking out of an apple or
something
did you ever steal the screens from a
sink that was always big
you can unscrew like your kitchen sink
or your sink in the back screen and
there's a bunch of screens in there oh
just pull one out you put it in the
ratchet head and it does yeah
yeah we didn't use that we just used a
straight up ratchet head my dad had been
like hey what is my quarter inch
oh yeah smell like a good [ __ ] time
that or uh we used to
in the biking days we would steal
people's hubcaps on their car
the chrome ones were big dude every once
in a while you see somebody that had
like a dice
or like a skull and crosstalk
every once in a while you get like the
badass guy who had a bullet and oh and
that was like big points because you're
like not only is this gonna look sick on
my bike but we might die doing this yeah
this could be this is dangerous he might
give us another bullet you know but uh
that was big we we were big on that we
go to like car shows and we're like
yeah we like pretend like entire shoes
and get in yeah put them on our chromies
at car shows yeah
go [ __ ] go over the [ __ ] sources
you know what i mean yeah and as an
adult now i would look back and if
somebody saw the chromies i'd be pissed
but that was like that was like a thing
like yeah you stole when they were big
everybody stole chrome when i was a kid
it was the ornaments on top of the car
that's crap i can break them off rip off
a [ __ ] thing he's actually a
misdemeanor right there that's actually
jail time i always do that people would
wear them as chains yeah i know the
cadillac one right yeah yeah the
cadillac yeah chromies were uh those are
sick put them on the bike chromies were
great and not one girl would ever look
i'm gonna be like yeah please pull up
[ __ ] validate me throw that out
oh yeah the back tire is going
skidding up somewhere you feel real cool
true to true gang let's talk about
stamps.com stamps.com stamps.com you
don't want to be waiting around in the
line at the post office when you got
stuff to do stamps.com you can mail ship
print everything from your home office
or your office i don't know if you got a
lease whatever you're doing i'm pretty
sure you said raining around but uh
guys you don't want to be at the post
office while that hectic holiday
shopping traffic you know what i mean
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels access exclusive discounts for
ups and usps service all year long it
makes sense it makes sense especially if
your business sends more mix
hey let's get the steaming that's keep
it pg will you um especially if you're
sending more stuff packages of mail
during the holiday holiday stuff you got
to get it out um like we always say save
time and money this holiday season with
stamps.com sign up with the promo code
garbage for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free pros
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts
required just go to stamps.com click the
microphone the top of the home page
enter code garbage we do it that's how
we send out the march it's fantastic
stamps.com microphone on top of the
homepage garbage do it now
kippy let's talk about expressvpn
expressvpn yeah love them i'm just
learning out about vpn learning out
about it i'm learning that about it i'm
figuring it out uh-huh cause i like to
do you know i like that i like to keep
my privacy online sure let's just say
that yeah
gotta have a vpn and if you're gonna get
a vpn you gotta go express yeah these
big companies are all stealing our info
that's what they're doing you're leaving
a footprint everywhere you go when
you're online [ __ ] what you got it
turns out even in incognito mode do you
have on like google chrome or whatever
they're still peeking
they're looking to lose these big
corporations they're stealing all of our
info we're going to sell it off to each
other
um the ip address the whole nine yards
you but best of all espresso vpn is
super easy to use uh you'll get a random
ip address shared by many other
expressvpn customers makes it harder for
third parties to identify and harvest
your data they're out there protecting
you they harvest your organs these
companies are harvesting our data baby
yeah selling it uh so if you really want
to go incognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with the number one
number one rated vpn visit
expressvpn.com
garbage and get an extra three months
for free that's express e x p r e s s v
p n dot com
garbage go to expressvpn.com slash
garbage now to learn more do it now back
to the show
was your was your belly button ever an
any
no audi any audi yeah no no no it's just
a normal belly button also do they
change they do really i don't think what
do you all got
i'm an innie yeah i'm a goddamn american
yeah i think we're all anything
i don't know yeah yeah any dude i
thought only like babies had audi's
babies just be coming out and just
[ __ ] rocked up yeah
it's all screwballs when they get out of
there yeah holy is this your way of
telling us that you had an audi and then
your stomach ate it sucked out i was
always in any anybody who started out as
an audi weird that kid was always weird
yeah
i didn't like it
have you ever had an email address that
had the numbers six nine or four twenty
in it
definitely
uh
or a screen name i definitely have i was
trying to think of what it was like
[ __ ] cottonmouth king six nights yeah
oh there had to be there had to be um
yeah dude i
i'm trying to think what it was
or i remember one of them i forget what
the the front part was but i know the
last three number slice digits was m80
because i really thought fireworks were
cool oh my god yeah m80 fireworks the
ones that could go with the waterproof
wicks you throw those on the water and
blow up did you ever have time for a 12
year old oh yeah because we also we were
pretty close to not close but you could
drive to chinatown and they just don't
they would sell fireworks to a third
grader
we would buy a bunch of those
firecrackers for like a dollar and then
we just blow up random [ __ ] they weren't
good do you get your hands on some m80s
as a kid that's crazy yes i remember i
put one ins or aol name was m80 and i
don't know what i don't know why that's
tough yeah anything on aim what else bb
gun num chucks chinese stars i'm super
into airsofting and paintball guns
growing up really i literally one of my
questions if you ever owned a paintball
gun what are we talking here i know a
little bit about them oh really dude we
uh the gear yeah we had all of that you
gotta gear up that's part of it what are
you gonna you're acting like you're
going to combat you know you gotta strap
up yeah there was a local like indoor
paintball field
near
in my hometown so we would like help out
there just like play for free yeah so we
got super into it they would be like
tournaments on the weekends when we play
and [ __ ] like we got all into it and
then um
i was like eighth grade yeah that's
exactly i think that's the year you get
i was into it in eight yeah i was
obsessed with i would like go on like
forums and look at all these guns and
all those crazy [ __ ] different paintball
guns and uh yeah and then i i don't know
what happened it was just like a
sophomore i realized chicks were cool
that's what happened yeah it was all all
just dude dominated and then girls like
we're gonna go to the movies and i'm
like what if we took a night off from
paintball
but then you get shot with a paintball
gun in the neck and it kind of looks
like a hickey dude i got shot in the
neck you shoot me i'll shoot you all
right
we'll never tell anybody hey yeah we're
both just doing a dark closet you know
it was like how was your weekend oh
that's [ __ ] nuts pretty crazy dude
yeah
i forgot her name
yeah who gave you a hickey on your
forehead
yeah that's a cool thing yeah i was
super into that we were just outdoor
[ __ ] i remember i had a zippo lighter
growing up
what was on it that's killing me here
that's pretty pro color what was on it
it was uh there was nothing on it but it
was like a royal blue almost the same
tin as a royal
dance the dance
yeah it was like the royal blue i kind
of like had a shine to it and i was
[ __ ] how else are you gonna like the
m80s i mean what are we doing here i was
stoked
dude i was waiting for people to ask if
i could light their cigarette i would do
like the light on your jeans
horseshoe oh yeah dude i was obsessed
with like like i was not on a good
trajectory it's just like zippos knives
a ninja star
i'd be terrified if i was a parent like
i there's a 13 on my house with ninja
stars and m80s yeah why would you have
ended up working at like a record store
in venice beach or something like that i
don't even know
maybe like at an airsoft maybe like cops
paintball gumballs yeah like at a paint
like a store for payload guys yeah yeah
like diamondback buffer paintball gun
you never worked in a smoke shop did you
no i worked at a frozen yogurt store
though
pretty classy
yeah
okay yeah a lot what was the vacation
situation for the wallaces growing up
we go to like palm springs because they
had like a time share there time share
travel
time
we were having a nice time we were
talking about business hard working kids
waiting for the rolex
that's good use bmw i'm excited this is
jesus
share whose was that uh
mom and dad's yeah oh but they did yeah
this is the stuff the internet needs to
be were they about these times
yeah that's crazy what's that they were
they about the time share life they
weren't continually going the time share
pitches and stuff right no once you have
the one i think they just had the one in
palm springs do you know who the other
family was that had it i have no idea
it's not it's no it's not that it's not
just like one family
it's there's a bunch of different i
forget
you it's it's really outdated you get
like one you know it's owned it's owned
by it's owned by a company who owns like
a bunch of them and then you buy they go
hey you give us x amount of money and
you own this
where you have to rent it out like you
get it two weeks a year or whatever yeah
or three weeks a year it doesn't you're
like forcing yourself to go on a
vacation yeah so then you're like you
got to take it by the end of the year
otherwise you forfeit the money yeah i
don't know if airbnb was a subscription
service yes
it's a subscription airbnb where you're
like i got to use this every you know
yeah i don't know how that plays off you
probably saved some money i'd imagine
but i don't think so i mean they i think
they're they're known to prey on yeah
not
super smart people any extended family
not a shot at your parents i'm just
saying
they pray they pray on low income they
do i watch a documentary on no i it's
kind of guy who will bring a chicken
finger on it here
that's a great way to put it they're
just waiting at the terminal being like
there's one excuse me again
barbecue sauce on the flight that's our
guy no i mean the more you explain it
the more i'm like well i don't know why
my parents would do that well they were
they dude they hit huge in the 80s and 9
or like early 90s for some reason and
like i had family and friends that did
it and i never understood i remember
like you partially own a place in mexico
what the [ __ ] is going on here yeah it's
really weird but they sit you down they
it's like a high pressure sales pitch
and then they go hey for like 500 bucks
today you can get this
in a year this in two years oh yeah it's
like don't you want to stay at the top
of a hotel in las vegas type thing yeah
i got you i got you yeah huh man those
wallaces are bonkers any lottery winners
in the family no no lottery winners any
extended family members ever stay with
you for a long period of time
not really anybody sleep on the couch a
lot
no growing up no no somebody falls
asleep on the couch mom or dad did you
have a garage we did have a garage is
there a refrigerator in there yeah the
classic white fridge yeah girl shout out
to the garage fridge baby yeah i had
that that's like up in the ring i don't
know what the texture was but it almost
felt like a leathery football sure yeah
yeah yeah no but it's got that like uh
fake
texture yeah yeah i don't know what
unnecessary yeah juice sodas ice pops
that kind of thing in there
uh
meat was in the freezer the fridge was
just like water bottles and like a would
have been like a healthy like a like uh
was that [ __ ] hanes soda it's not haynes
what was it i don't know jones maybe
jones what maybe jones soda damn y'all
talking about doc browns are you hansen
is that a soda sounds classy i think i
know what you're doing it's a can
you get it from like trader joe's i'll
pull it out i don't know what haynes
hand soda hansen soda
hansen
sounds nice
bob
i don't know it's i thought hanson soda
handsome beverage beverage hear this is
this it
that's that baking soda i mean what i
don't think this is oh like this have
you ever seen this oh
no but it looks real no i've seen that
that looks like out of a cartoon that's
like that at the organic store that's
good stuff yeah that's like the soda
they would drink on friends yeah
yeah i think it's like my mom's living
like your soda like my mom would be the
girl that would be like she would buy
like lucky charms trader joe's version
you know sure yeah okay like lucky farms
or something you're like i don't know
about that yeah it's in a bag what was
her uh best dish that she would make oh
man she was actually really good chef
good cook she would make like jeffy said
uh yeah what i just think you misused
the word to be honest with you well no
she was doing the reviews for the
restaurant yeah but anything against my
dad's omelets was you know unbeatable
she made a
really good uh she would do like a sweet
and sour chicken but she like bread it
and fry it there with some sauce own
sweet and sour chicken's pretty good
it's pretty classy she did uh
who would have thought a woman who wants
a crime ship would make homemade shoes
like thai i think they got wrapped up in
a high pressure sales they didn't know
what was going on with the timeshare
they made a bet yeah yeah is that all
you guys would do is go to the timeshare
you ever step out to disney world
disneyland europe sometimes but not not
very much like we didn't travel too much
as family we had done the hawaii thing
like two or three times just to bring it
up again okay how old were you when you
got your passport
uh i did go to london when i was 16.
okay
canada what's canada no it just has like
some family [ __ ] but i remember went to
canada i was 16 and uh date i think his
drinking age is 18 there yeah and i was
16 and they didn't card me and i was
like this is i'm living yeah that might
be the new dan b i might be believing
out here
this was big this is big news for me so
uh
yeah i think other than that we went to
london one time and canada was like the
only two bills i had a passport for that
then did you guys have a pool growing up
no neighbor at a pool though
about their inground in ground okay
above is hey come on yikes anybody have
a standalone hot tub any aunts uncles
just a hot tub
my
cousins did oh
yeah it was on a wooden deck they always
are
yeah yeah it's never in the guest house
okay
a wooden desk painted red yeah yeah yeah
yeah brutal man that's a tough one yeah
and it was always out of commission you
know
waiting on a park there's nothing even
in it it's just storage for them you
idiots
uh anyone in your family own a pt
cruiser
uh oh boy no i they didn't but i think
there were some weird ones in no i don't
think so okay anyone own a uh jet ski
no no jet ski you don't know jet ski no
i do not now now with a little bit of
cash have you have you gone back and got
a bunch of bb guns or paintball guns no
i should have nothing like that no i
should just be next for me huh
you're moving on you're maturing that's
good maturing
anyone in your family refer to the
bathroom as the john no
the commode the loo anything none of
that okay uh
yeah no i don't think so same with your
family have a black toilet
no
is that good or bad because we found out
only people with mud they're only in
rich beef it's like super new money [ __ ]
i was going to say that's money that's
yeah it's wealthy yeah yeah it's real
new money [ __ ] yeah no no no we have a
toilet so we're like my dad goes you got
to jiggle the handle
or else it'll run all day it's like this
makes us
i'm like hey dad oh my parents they have
a there's a leak in their roof
in the kitchen
and they cut out the patch to fix it and
it's just been a block of drywall it's
not even patched it's just a block of
drywall that's measured kind of close to
and they're remodeling the countertops
they just got marble countertops so they
still have a whole patch like when are
we going to fix this man
my dad's my dad's very like i don't know
if it's like a garbage move or a cheap
move but he would like he's the king of
all that [ __ ] like the instead of having
the dog running around in the office
he built like he put like a suitcase
with like a skateboard in front of it to
block the dog out instead of spending
twenty nine dollars for the thing on a
gate yeah to keep the dog out yeah it's
a makeshift contraptions
to keep the dog out of his office he's
got luggage and a skateboard so the
skateboard who's your dad kevin
mcallister
it would be like a skateboard that goes
against the wall and you put a suitcase
on the side to back it up for the so it
doesn't fall over jesus yeah not great
engineering you could have just done two
campbell soup cans to hold it right now
yeah yeah but he that's the type of guy
he is he's like very like makeshift like
handy okay
okay your family ever been thrown out of
a restaurant no
can't say
hmm did your parents ever buy the
products off products off tv such as a
shamwow or a slap chop
any clappers at the house no chia pets
none of those
ronco
i don't know what that is
um
rotisserie chicken he could be too young
no my mom had a uh a bowl she bought
where you like put this salad in it and
you tap a thing on top and spins all the
water off yeah that'll work
thank you yeah i had one of those they
never worked but it was also like i feel
like you just rinse it under water i
don't know sure like you just it was
more so fun it would just spin getting
just get the water off and you could
also tie dye t-shirts in there
yeah exactly that'll work salad spinner
i'll give you that that's garbage that's
up there
um
have you ever worn axe body spray oh
yeah today
no no i remember one time my mom found
alex body spare my backpack in like
eighth grade and she goes are you using
this to cover up the scent of weed she's
like yeah for sure yeah yeah i was like
no mom this the [ __ ] eyedrops are for
but uh
no she uh she thought that was uh for
the weed but yeah that was big dude i
was in high school when that dropped and
the [ __ ] locker room jesus oh
everybody had their own like a hookah
lounge up in that business you did not
strike a match yeah that thing would
have went up yeah
it was serious i used tag and then old
spice house that was even worse oh my
god
body spray or regular cologne there was
there was a silver can i don't know who
it was by
if you're doing old spice that's pretty
nice i don't think it was old some kids
like you that's great might have been
tagged silver bonnie's ring that was
trash tag was real trash
[Music]
there's no way that's going to come up
silver body spray i don't know but he is
pretty good at the internet he's proven
so maybe he does know what he's talking
about silver body spray for pubescent
teams who like to smoke weed
dude like i don't know what it is
it's not gonna show up this is oh well
it's like body spray like actually paint
people painting themselves silver
what's the shower routine now will you
uh brush your teeth in the shower i do
brush my teeth in the shower
whole family do that
you learned that when you were a kid you
learned from your mom and dad uh i think
i'm the only one that be doing do you
leave the toothbrush in there yeah
but here's the thing this that money
baby i got one in the shower one by the
[ __ ] sink
come on shout out to youtube.com yeah
yeah
24th every month electrics they're old
school no electrics just old school okay
you pee in the shower oh yeah
okay i like it where where where are you
you guys be in the shower 100 i'll be in
the shower even if i'm not in the shower
100 you think i give a [ __ ] i did it
this morning yeah i i went through a
phase where i just get drunk and pee in
the sink you ever do that yeah it's a
good one yeah yeah it's like a urinal
the same [ __ ] goes the same place i know
it's not that great though yeah you're
actually saving water though
yeah now okay yeah but you like do you
give it a quick little courtesy like one
wrench oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah just in your day a little
splash do you live with your lady i
don't like me i do we just moved in a
month ago really all right okay that's
nice she brushed her teeth in the shower
i don't think so yeah no not because
she's not an animal yeah she's like
she's like more of a normal yeah yeah
king size bed king size bed how many
pillows are we talking four four you
sleep with all of them i do do you have
do you sleep you like i gotta cuddle the
[ __ ] out of those pillows i need that
security baby what about one between the
legs nah all right
all right yeah
fan yeah yeah yeah see i like a good
ceiling fan or i like a good ceiling fan
who doesn't trevor she she said that the
ceiling fan is trashy i don't give a
[ __ ] it feels good it's a neutral tone
on the body it covers everything he's
good this guy gets it ceiling fan is
classy
a ceiling fan is classy what's trashy is
having a regular fan right next to your
face when you're sleeping that's what i
think that's garbage they can both be
trashy so what do you just sleep in the
heat and you [ __ ] take it like a man
what's the dust situation on that
ceiling fan not great
i'm gonna cheat you straight here guys i
saw a trick online you take a pillowcase
yeah put it over there and then you just
[ __ ] choke it and you just rip it off
like a condi yeah and it comes right off
really yeah it doesn't you put it in
yeah it doesn't get in the air because
that's the family and it falls on them
you pull it back pretty good just have a
dusty pillow really good cleaning lady
uh
i we don't have one but like we just
moved in like yeah yeah yeah will you be
getting one i don't know probably hmm
classy gentlemen okay hopefully
parking parking spot with the with
okay but i gave her the the the
gentleman oh man you know well there's a
homeless guy in front of our door one
day uh and as i was like she gets up for
work like five a.m yeah so i was like
yeah you should probably just go to the
garage yeah yeah
for sure yeah it's the right move for a
second i thought you were telling the
homeless guy that yeah oh yeah he's
gonna start working around five a.m yeah
see those bushes over there great place
to pop out yeah
right always has a lot of cash on her
too oh yeah
and that angle you're hitting on the
ring camera so you're good
you got the ring got the ring camera
hey
going back and forth are we talking just
the front doorbell or we got full house
coverage yeah just the front door bell
okay
yeah but that's like enough i feel like
yeah you just gotta you know some eyes
on check your six because yeah you know
that's all too much security you get a
little like that's a little long you
become
and [ __ ] paranoid would you happen to
know your dad's favorite singer or actor
my dad's favorite band is grateful dead
don't know his favorite actor my dad
loves grateful dead
christmas has never been easier every
year i just type in like grateful dead
golf balls and he's like these are
[ __ ] magnificent [ __ ] trevor you're
the greatest son in the world he plays
golf though oh yeah big golf member of a
country club nah he he just goes like
the local okay okay all right
all right
we'll pack his own sandwich though we'll
package to the take to the clock and
chicken tender and and one single
chicken tender yeah i like it
uh well back to that where did he get
the chicken tender previous where did he
where did it
originate we
we went to like a brunch spot and then
they had like a chicken waffle type
thing and uh i think this wasn't at the
airport no no no
it traveled the hotel
it had a great trajectory dude it was
running spots that night
[ __ ] restaurant hotel airport through
tsa waiting this is all in the pocket by
the way and then about in the pocket
about 30 minutes in the air i get the
tap on the shoulder
the people next to him probably thought
he was to try to take this thing right
into the atlantic just i don't know what
ocean is near hawaii but and this is
recent air marshall sir put the nuggets
down yeah this was over the summer oh
[ __ ] maybe foreign
do you fly first class when you go to
gigs only if i'm like doing like a
vacation with the lady okay yeah other
than that it's like i don't i don't mind
the i'll i'll do like business plus for
like the extra 80 bucks sure and you're
like this is nice because you've got to
be getting recognized a decent yeah
it is i'm sure it's probably nice to
kind of cause i i was in the elevator
with you in moon tower yeah and we got
off and there was literally it was like
a [ __ ] it was like off youtube
there's a kid sitting there with a thing
of white claws oh my god
didn't know you were gonna be there and
the door opened up and he sees trevor
because holy [ __ ] dude i'm the biggest
fan you're like oh yeah it's pretty on
brand yeah yeah yeah that guy tours with
me so
no but yeah it's like for in my head if
you see some kid like me in first class
like oh this kid thinks he got it we
should be a business business plus like
all right
hard working young man
he got three extra inches for that
kneecap okay
are you um what are the cards do you
have an amex
chase
yeah so i got like a business one but
then also the chase college account
yeah i got this sapphire but the metal i
don't even know if they use metal i
don't know what it is yeah it's like a
flimsy metal i don't know i got it yeah
we got we just got we just got one which
one oh the ammo
the amex is something nice i mean it's
only got like a two thousand dollar
credit limit but but metal yeah oh let
me hear that bad boy it's like you can
feel it more than you it's got a little
tang it's got a little tank oh yeah yeah
yeah
oh yeah the girlfriend's got the same
one yeah yeah can't buy a rolly with it
though no i can't even buy a swatch with
this thing this is maxed out to texas
dude we are tanking that's patreon.com
all right what else you got oh let's see
you got a couple
one i have but i have a would you
consider yourself good at laser tag
probably probably yeah yeah i was all
into the the paintball
so i would say i'm decent at it
have you ever watched the implosion of a
building
online oh yikes
that's even worse somehow i feel like
that's like one of those things you're
just scrolling you're not scrolling
through it you're like watching the live
stream guys
they're about to blow
you get up at like 5 a.m
what's the diet situation you're cooking
at the house
uh i cook breakfast i'm like my dad if i
do i do a good breakfast in the morning
and then whatever the [ __ ] else enters
my body there's that i don't really care
about it so yeah i could be better with
that but i just cook i just cook really
basic [ __ ] like just like ground beef
and rice microwavable rice and i'm like
there we go yeah microbial rice that's
all you need
um growing up or do they currently or do
you now did your parents keep the
batteries in the refrigerator
uh they did
they did yeah yeah it's not a great look
they never keep cash in the freezer or
jewelry cash in the freezer yeah that's
a real dirtbag thing i love it
no
not no nothing are you a cash guy i
guess i put yeah do you like always have
a couple of bucks on you because i'm
like not a cash guy ever it's like hit
or miss i'll either have like i guess
from spots sometimes yeah yeah yeah
spots around town you get like 20 bucks
and you just keep it on you but yeah i
keep it on me for like valet type [ __ ]
yeah what about the pet situation
growing up
uh pet situation i had uh two cats and
then the dog was like a later thing what
were their names
uh that's pretty cute man hugs and uh
kisses for the cats
it's uh yeah i haven't said that out
publicly wow i could have just lied wow
i could have just lied dude it's not
gross that's bad it's not great ah yeah
hugs and kisses these are for short time
share people oh yeah
oh yeah the cats had their own time
share you know
uh the dog's name and this is just my
sister being on some nut [ __ ] she named
the dog charlie but it's a girl so i
just that's okay charlie
well charlie's angels yeah i think she
was influenced by that what kind of dog
was charlie puggle
pug beagle they're nice those are good
dogs just not bad straight pug little
trash pug mix not bad i'll give you that
no fish no hermit crabs
i didn't have a fish guinea pig
oh okay you guys gonna love this so i
aside so my sister growing up had a pet
rat oh my god
and when it died they had a funeral in
the backyard oh my god did they bury it
in the backyard oh yeah she worked at a
lab at this time or something that a
peck
yeah oh those are the creepiest ones
dude i don't i don't know why she wanted
a rat growing up i don't oh i forget its
name [ __ ] pet right or something
stupid
turkey bastard or some [ __ ] i don't know
what the [ __ ] his name was i forget
that's the [ __ ] nail on the clock i
had a goldfish i had a goldfish i wanted
the fair that lived for way too long uh
thought i was gonna die in like two
weeks to live for i think three years a
goldfish yeah goddamn what was that what
was his name i have no idea yeah okay i
think you should look at him like a face
i guess
hmm yeah i don't know god damn that's
i got one more from the patreon justin
because we're we're all into it we're in
the same realm so as you guys know when
you're doing the patreon we'll answer
your question on the air and this one's
just funny this is from caitlin uh ever
try to train a pet to retrieve a
beverage for you
but those when you see those videos
that's it that's too much time on your
hand and real dirtbag [ __ ] no i haven't
but i i that would be something i would
aspire to your dad charlie get me a beer
do something i saw a guy turn off a
light switch with a laser pointer the
other day with the cat you shine at the
light switch and the cat goes the bat at
it
that's pretty good that's just smart
that's really smart yeah that's just
that's just good but no she left the rat
out with the rapper running around the
house she would like hold it it didn't
smell good i don't know what oh god i
don't know she
she lives in williamsburg she's one of
those people
[Music]
she might still own a rat you know i got
news for her she just thanked the whole
wildless family oh yeah this kid's trash
yeah oh validated yeah i could turn my
head i could turn my head on the
timeshare but you guys got jammed up
yeah you guys were drinking what you
know your parents were drinking one
night but a rat yeah that was loose
cottonmouth kings is off the bat that's
not good that's grand slam trash right
there
knocking out of the trailer park right
there real trash man oh buddy we love
you what a [ __ ] fantastic episode
thank you so much for coming in thanks
for having me this is great what do you
got coming up you want the folks out
there to know i got a tour coming up
it's announcing on the 15th uh i don't
know is
when is this here uh
probably before the 15th yeah yeah yeah
uh yeah next monday i got a tour coming
up it's a big theater tour it's my first
theater tour very excited for this it's
called the are you that guy tour uh
it's like nobody's really good nobody
[ __ ] knows my name they're just like
you're the internet guys are you that
guy so it's kind of like it's playing on
that and uh it's just kind of like it
just felt
and fit the tone and uh you know it's
just a life about people like knowing
who you are but not knowing who you are
they know the videos so and this is just
straight stand up there's no characters
it's just uh you know just me just
[ __ ] yelling about random [ __ ] and uh
uh tickets on trevor wallacecomedy.com
other than that you can find me on
trevor waltz and i got a podcast called
stiff socks and i'd love to have you
guys on you guys i think you have my boy
on tomorrow he's got blasting coming
yeah yeah it's my co-host that boy i
don't know if he's trash she's got a big
foot fetish though so oh yeah
good-looking kid too good looking kid
loves body on him loves feet so bring
that up yeah he knew that he's a weird
he's a weird sexual deviant kind of guy
loves feet used to think his mom was hot
he's a character don't tell me he told
us this will ambush him with it yeah
first question yeah i hear you're a real
pervert yeah are you a tits or a foot
guy and just throw him off
and he's like oh this is my kind of
podcast dim the lights i heard you like
your mom's feet your little pervert
that'll get them riled up give them a
hard time or i can give you guys some
good info
but yeah man it's called stiff socks
every wednesday we'll get you guys on
whenever you're in la or if we have any
time uh in new york dudes love it man
thank you so much gang the great trevor
wallace ladies and gentlemen what do you
got for him uh guys uh next couple of
weeks in the middle of december we're
gonna be in uh albany syracuse and
hartford connecticut get those tickets
come see us the last shows for the year
and then uh 2022 we're lining [ __ ] up
all over the [ __ ] country uh merch
drop there's merch currently available
going going to be available until
november 18th the link will be in the
description get it while it lasts gang
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace